خرافه ان الصهيونيه ليس لها علاقه
بالاستعمار هي جزء من الا مشروع
استعماري الصهيونيه ليست استعمارا قطعا
والصهيونيه واليهوديه هما الشيء نفسه
وبالتالي سيكون من قبيل الخرافه ان تقول
انك ان كنت معاد للصهيونيه فانت معادل
للساميه فسر لي هذا الامر هل يمكن ان تكون
يهوديا وليست صهيونيا في واقع
اليوم يمكن ان تكون يهوديا وان لا تكون
صهيونيا ويمكن ان تكون صهيونيا من دون ان
تكون يهو
هناك كثير من المسيحيين الصهاينه والذين
هم على قدر كبير من الاهميه بايدن يتحدث
عن صهيون ته بفخر غبي
يعني اهم مجموعه تدعم اسرائيل اليوم في
امريكا ليست اليهود بل المسيحيون الصهاينه
كانت المجموعه الاهم التي قادت بريطانيا
الى منح فلسطين لليهود عام
1917 ومنهم بالفور صهاينه ومسيحيون يمكن
ان تكون يهوديا من دون ان تكون صهيون
الصهيونيه كانها دين مستقل او حاله
مستقله ايديولوجيه عف دين مجاز
ايديولوجيه انها
ايجيه عربي وصهيوني صحيح الصهيونيه
ايديولوجيه واليهوديه
عقيده صحيح كما تعلمون للاسف لدينا بعض
الحمدله الحمد لله الحمد لله يوجد البعض
لكنهم ليسوا كثيرين والحمد لله لكن نعم
اعتقد انه مهم جدا لان في كل مرحله من
مراحل تاريخ الصهيونيه لم تكن غالبيه
اليهود في العالم صهاينه وحتى اليوم اعتقد
ان غالبيه اليهود في العالم ليسوا صهاينه
لكن ماذا حدث لماذا لدينا انطباع بان كل
اليهود في العالم هم صهاينه ايضا لان
المؤسسات اليهوديه هي مؤسسات
ولكن كما تعلمون لم يكن اليهود في
بريطانيا وامريكا جزءا من المؤسسه
بالضروره وهذا عمل منظم تحويل المؤسسات
اليهوديه الى صهيونيه عمل منظم تم على مدى
قرن
كامل اهم ما نتج عن تلك الخرافه ان السلاح
الرئيس الذي تملكه اسرائيل اسكاتك ان كنت
في لندن لاسكات ان كنت في الدنمارك هو
القول انه بانتقاد اسرائيل فانت معادل
للساميه وانت ضد اليهوديه وانا اقول لا لا
انا يهودي ولا يمكن ان اكون ضد اليهوديه
لكنني ضد الصهيونيه لانني ضد العنصريه
لانني ضد الاستعمار انا ضد الاستعمار
الاستيطاني انا ضد التطهير العرقي لهذا
انا ضد الصهيونيه وهذا لا علاقه له
باليهوديه المشكله الرئيسيه لبعض الناس في
فلسطين كما تعلمون هي الشباب الفلسطيني
الذي يعيش في الضفه الغربيه وان اليهود
الوحيدين الذين يعرفونهم هم الجنود
والمستوطنون لذلك عندما يقولون يهودا لا
يقصدون كل اليهود عندما يقولون يهود
يقصدون الجيش الاسرائيلي والمستوطنين
الاسرائيليين ولكن اسرائيل هي التي خلقت
هذا الارتباك وليس الفلسطينيون خلقت
اسرائيل هذا الالتباس بانك ان كنت يهوديا
فانت صهيوني لا لا ان كنت صهيونيا فانت
تؤمن بمشروع معين واذا كنت تؤمن
بالانسانيه الدوليه كما اؤمن انا فلا
يمكنك دعم هذا
المشروع
[موسيقى]
project